um we're talking about rap monster and
bts we're talking about bts dude
if i want my son to just pipe down and
zone out
i put on any bts song and he goes nuts i
was going to film it for chin he gets
crunk yeah he put he played that song
and he played dynamic
cool to do laundry too oh inch yeah yeah
i want to say that
it's cool let me open up the house
let me separate these loads j-hope he's
a he's another rapper too yeah
okay oh they they've been popping since
2013
well they got big in last like what
three years jen
i would say the last three three four
years three free like see that's hard
work
blew up that's hard work starting in
2013.
didn't they come together like one
direction did they did yeah were all
individuals than that then some
new shows like yeah put them together
now he makes all the money
crazy that's what would you boys do this
weekend malik
did your queen let you watch
okay for one i don't ask for permission
we just like kind of like suggested it
i'm like hey babe
the lego game is coming on can i turn
the show yeah she said yeah i'll play
she said yeah she said y'all pay for the
cable channel
right well we have i'm in premium her
tight i'm still holding that tight
but let me tell you she bought me these
socks she brought you about those stamps
yeah yeah yeah like you're saying i got
a little hair on her a little bit
hey is it just me like i was watching my
girl doesn't watch
basketball and she's like this is stupid
what like when they won they're like
celebrating there's nobody around
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's good the
coaches all we
did you hear one game go yeah in the
back
wait hold on it's kind of awkward that
was awkward i cried last night no you
did it correct
why they were three to one
you also got the best team in the league
what are you crying lebron has been on
top
for this long and it's unprecedented
what he's doing right now like let's
just
be honest what's up we're not
appreciative unprecedented what this
guy's doing at 37
have been doing it for lo bro i remember
when lebron was great he's 37
he was no he's 34 35 36 but it's his
17th year in the league and literally
he's been like a part of my childhood
for him to just get another ring
i cried my girl looked at me differently
what's interesting about lebron is it's
like it's rare you get this like he is
who they packaged him as you know i'm
saying like he's on the front cover
sports illustrated
next mj and it's very rare guys actually
live up to the live up to the highest he
was very higher and more
yeah like the grace ever like i mean
there's argument for it
magic johnson made a compelling argument
we'll move on from basketball because i
know my listeners like this
but uh i apologize like dude look at the
ratings of nba if nobody's watching that
we sure as [ __ ]
you don't want to put that on it all
right you tuned in for different [ __ ]
magic johnson made a great uh assessment
he goes
i think lebron might be the greatest all
time because he's dealing with pressure
that we didn't have to deal with
like social media every you know forum
every freaking uh countdown show every
espn show fox show it's just all like
hate and negativity and there's just so
much pressure on lebron to perform
never got caught he never got caught
cheating
but that but i don't want to touch that
brendan
i don't want to touch brandon but that's
the that's what to me that's what makes
it
when magic sounds like oh he's right
like jordan it was like yeah
i guess if you turn on the news they
might cover your [ __ ] but no one's
talking about you negative
yeah like there wasn't all this
animosity all the time correct i respect
that
yeah that makes sense yeah they're like
they're dealing with it it's just
you can't say he's better than michael
it's just a different time it's just a
difference
you'll have your jordan fans and lebron
fans and speaking of greatest all the
time
bro did you see that knockout this week
oh yeah you posted it he's not oh you're
saying this that knockout did i put
who posted it catboy's that knockout oh
they're not with the kick right
oh yeah do you say the greatest knockout
yeah exactly
i don't think i will it's it again it's
tough to say greatest fall time but it's
top five
that was top five top five you guys see
it hell yeah
that was crazy i think it's one of the
most watched
uh highlights of ufc ever no that came
he kicked his face off they don't have
it on there no no i i don't have it
yeah it was on there it was on
sportszone that was insane
that looked like me and malik fighting
out there too bruh it was
just the way we haven't seen the way he
you know we've never seen somebody do it
that way
he's a heavyweight right oh no oh yeah
what's his weight no i think they're
are they 155 170 oh thank you everywhere
you ever seen a heavyweight doug
well yeah oh no i'm saying they love you
they were you're a heavyweight of course
yeah though those guys no those guys
aren't heavyweights but uh
damn you struggling to fight a damn
chance
chin is only the greatest knockout
struggle bus over here
super strong i mean it literally
happened everywhere
i'm gonna get a good one i'm gonna get
it right if you go to twitter just ufc
i know ufc twitter hold on
i got this i got this he's going through
the wrong page making a lebron
you see
now k.o it's hard to say uh greatest of
all time just because it was on the
prelims
the stakes aren't as high like to me
it'd be hard to put that over amsterdam
silva front kicking
for the [ __ ] out yeah because that was
for the world
title yeah and that was the main event
it's like vitor belfort is like one of
the greatest ever do it yeah i'm not
saying those guys are bad fighters but
neither one's one of the greatest to
ever do it not yet anyway
yeah they're young okay but as far as
athletically [ __ ]
up there it is oh there's right here god
damn it
[Music]
for one he should have been knocked out
for the haircut two uh
this way you don't think about that dude
flew all the way to abu dhabi
got knocked out the worst knockout we've
seen in years yeah and he's going viral
for that
then he has to wake up to that the next
day he's like oh [ __ ]
and then get on a plane and fly 18 hours
back to where the [ __ ] he's from
i know that's what nobody talks about
and he's getting half his pay when i got
knocked out
i lived right down the street you know
what i'm saying what do you mean he got
knocked out by who
uh it was in uh this kid in junior high
and i told you
before oh yeah oh you said it was the
king in the state was on here
i think oh i told him kings yeah you got
knocked out mm-hmm by a kid like a
younger kid right
he was younger and shorter he was little
you didn't tell me this
yeah i did they removed it from the
sports center shout out to robert what
did you say they took it off
sportscenter
it said restricted because too violent i
don't know maybe i don't know [ __ ] the
way here's what's on a bunch of
[ __ ] they can do that wait he's right
here right there
oh that was so quick 12.5 million it has
to be the most viral clip of all time
for ufc yeah i retweeted it
[Music]
yeah damn that was devastating i would
never want that to happen to me i
i'd rather get nothing that's like worst
like when you're visualizing back in the
locker room you don't visualize
that you're really like oh man if he
beats me about this i know right
yeah i don't want to get tired
what if he gets me behind yeah if
someone's like hey dude
he you're going to hold on his foot he's
doing a spinning heel kick and knock you
the [ __ ] out
and then he's going to go viral and 40
million people are gonna watch it and he
did that that was quick
you gotta get some jordan that was so
quick they're middleweights yeah yeah
you gotta get some jordan
joaquin buckley give him some jordans or
some vans they know his name now
hell yeah he's a striker everyone's
gonna be looking for him now oh really
st louis
well they'll be looking forward to his
next fight you don't go that viral or
not
yeah nuts now you gotta live up to that
i know he was talking [ __ ] after right i
heard him no he wasn't yeah
he was in the gate well he's just
excited he's just talking about [ __ ] no
no no no he's
a bad sport he's pretty right he's not
humble no no i'm talking about dude but
did you see your boy dwight howard
oh yeah what do you
yeah we won we won i like
this you have to bleep out so
you're gonna have to
so he goes to his you haven't seen this
no he goes to his uh instagram
uh like instagram live and he
accidentally posted his text
conversation
like it's on there and it's him and his
wife arguing no she's like you didn't
tell me you weren't with those girls
last night he's like who are you talking
about want to change
she's all having fun tonight yeah it's
like god damn [ __ ]
nothing before the game yeah this is
before was that before no it's out
i'm sorry he'll celebrate so he's
literally celebrating his wife is like
yo what the [ __ ] you doing
yeah but how do you do that
he's probably pausing when he comes on
his eyes oh he's screaming like paulie
she like must be true show me bruh she
hit him with the thumbs up emoji
tonight have fun that's and she never
she didn't mean
nothing in that sentence turn up know
yeah she didn't mean anything exactly
don't stop being condescended damn your
man just won a championship yeah
enjoy the championship yeah let him
enjoy that actually i didn't have i
don't wanna
you didn't i don't know what the hell
are you doing exactly well here's the
thing and then he posted
what was the girl he posted up with was
that his wife i don't know he posted a
picture with his girlfriend
i didn't know he was married well of
course either oh yeah
yeah 100 million yeah his boo i promise
you after like celebration with his boo
on his instagram yeah let's take a
little break from the
shenanigans listen there's nobody on the
planet like you
if you're listening to this there's
nobody like you all right
so why would you buy a generic mattress
built for everybody else why would you
do that
how about you check out helix sleep they
have a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preference to the perfect mattress
just for your thick ass that's right you
a thicky sleeping on your side
we got you covered your hot sleeper
covered you want a plush
firm bed with helix there's no confusion
all right
helix sleep was even awarded number one
best overall mattress pick of 2019
2020 by gq and wired magazine
at my crib i've used it forever you come
to my crib you sleep as a guest
you're sleeping on helix the match has
been good for years
people wake up and go my god no more
back pain it's the best i've ever slept
i go cool get out my house all right
just go to helixsleep.com fighter take
their two minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you
to a customized mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life they
have a 10 year warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they even pick it up for you
if you don't love it but you will
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders
and free pillows for you guys at
helixsleep.com
fighter that's helix sleep.com
fighter for up to 200 off this is one of
my favorite sponsors i use them all the
time after i get done with one of my
long ass bike rides
i am using liquid i v
man liquid iv it's one stick all right
you put in 16 ounces of water you get
two to three times the amount of
hydration as plain
water the flu season guess what holiday
season flu season
they line up man let liquid iv help
support your immune system
all right an essential vitamins we've
got you covered stay hydrated for the
holidays
uh liquid iv's best-selling hydration
multiplier now has three new flavors
guava watermelon apple pie not my fav
watermelon is though all right so uh i
love liquid iv it tastes delicious
you put in some cold water you shake it
up i do it after every bike ride i swear
by these guys
one servant of liquid iv provides the
same hydration again
as drinking two to three water bottles
alone
man they got essential vitamins uh
liquid iv is also on a
mission to change the world the company
has donated over five million servings
globally all right
liquid iv is available nationwide at
walmart in the beverage section
or just get it here man you can get 25
off when you go to liquid iv.com
use the code fighter at checkout that's
25 off
anything you order when you use the
promo code fighter at liquid iv.com get
better hydration today
at liquidity.com promo code fighter
are they good now i'm gonna go they
probably on this story they probably
she does not have them he's not no he
doesn't go to the shade room go to the
shade room
that's right that's why i get that's
where i got my news from guys that's why
i can't
change
yeah right there there we go right here
look at this so go down they got the
latest news
uh go down go down go down this page
looks fantastic
go down go down look at that so often
hold on yeah there's so much content
what is it right i think it's right wait
wait did you pass up the white now you
pass it up you pass it up did i pass
that
there's my right right here right okay
here press the live one click on this
one that's the live one we just watched
what we just saw
yeah that's what we just saw oh we did
yeah but yeah it's a picture of there
with his
his girl though i don't think so yeah
think so believe in me i saw it
believe him he's got a wife yeah that's
right yeah right here look told you
told you thought i was lying posted up
with his girl he's a queen
oh [ __ ] yeah she's nice right yeah she's
super bodied
that's what i'm saying was it look how
they look how they are on that first
their first shot right there
she's like pushing away a little bit i
love the comment look it says that
turn up tonight have fun is toxic
i know what that means i've been in this
gangster and there's not you know what
that will even [ __ ] up a world
championship it would
it would if you're going to [ __ ] like
yeah
his high's going to come down a little
bit you're bringing that high down
and it's not can you wait till then
that's the first one can you wait till
the next
morning nah what's that first one she's
like i don't give a [ __ ] about this
[ __ ] chance you're one in the bubble
one in the bubble bro you keep doing
that
mickey mouse ass ringing yeah
she a basketball player it looks like it
oh is she really oh they they met in the
bubble
that's the circle of love oh does she
play for wnba
wow it's like loving basketball all over
again yeah oh damn she plays uh
what is mark's oh she's playing smart
hell yeah what does she get mad oh she
bad
they both in l.a oh [ __ ] hold on dwight
dwight or right around the white the
dwight of ronaldo
[Laughter]
i'll tell you that something nobody
watches
is wnba that's a lot seven people
watched
the series 87 people how do you know
it's
seven people i'm being i'm being
generous maybe four
nobody watches that [ __ ] the only one i
noticed it's probably more than seven i
probably
when i say low i'm saying you and mal
could post a video taking a piss and get
more views
like nobody's there's just no way you
want to do that the only the only reason
they're aroused because the nba fund the
nba owns the wme it's the only reason
they're still around
my friend proposed to this girl at a
wnba game that's like respect no way
nobody gives a flying [ __ ] i bet she was
like
here there's nobody here
what's his name what's his name i wish
she was like
greg they're stupid i bet you know what
she's probably like greg are you doing
this because nobody's here
is that why you're doing this like she
wouldn't do it at the time people don't
know that i'm your main
chick yeah
that's how you know nobody in the game
the sure person shooting at the same
person all right
did you catch it this time
yeah he proposed at the wnba what a
gangster move
i didn't even know i was like okay you
got the lakers game everybody gonna see
it yeah
when we're not in cover times you ever
seen when they say no
yeah she could have said no there and
nobody wouldn't even notice yeah she's
probably
she was like get up okay she she's a
ride or die for him though
what to say yes to at a w w nba game
first of all i gotta question his entire
being
that he had tickets to wmu it probably
was free
free they give him alberts
the room they paper the [ __ ] out of
those rooms are you serious
dude you name somebody who's like damn
dog you get season tickets to the spark
old people no oh people like what what
don't watch the
goddamn la lakers they they told me
women are skilled basketball players
they got the most skilled the women are
more skilled than what we told you
when i lived nobody ever told you that
hey i tell you what people show up for
the mercury games phoenix mercury
uh maybe yeah i think i think the
seattle teams do the best like the
seattle
soccer team and uh uh what's her name
uh brittany brittany yeah brittany
griner brittany griner
some of them are bad ross not one of
them
diana rossi yeah right that is it i
think so
now that's when we're doing that no
she's on the mercury but she's like she
just want mvp right the girls
yeah yeah she just wants super beast
yeah they're talented i'm just saying no
no mercury has won a lot yeah that's
what i'm saying people show up to it
again you got to be careful those words
show up oh look at scotland
higgins is so so bad here's the thing
now if you ball and you get pregnant in
the middle of the season
the what happens what do they do wait
they date night
nine months see ya same with the ufc ufc
fighters like there's pregnant ufc
fighters and they just take two well
there's a currency she not is brittany
grinder not on the team anymore
i don't know i just typed in the team
players ah it doesn't matter though you
know oh no yeah she is
she's still on there she's a some are
super ballers ready grinding and dunk
yeah all right dude
i wonder what's that conversation where
you got to go back to you
he
bruh i used to valet her car she was
tall enormous
bro brendan now you got defense you and
brittany grinder 101.
that's all she does but let me get my
shots in man
i'm way stronger let's get that out yeah
she got in the fight with her girl she
went to jail for like oh yeah yeah
she talked like she taught like a dude
she got all bro she's got a deep voice
she's from louisiana she really
lsu right no she played at baylor yeah
she's baylor girl
oh wait but uh yes i think she got in a
fight with her was that beyonce or
something oh right there
she's a mugshot chin the only bug shot
on the
now page which one is the stud what's
that mean oh
britney's that you talking about the
dominant one no but they both like kind
of
uh you know which one come on no they
don't listen you don't dunk a basketball
and get all [ __ ] well can i say he's
in in the league as well is she really
is she yeah
yeah but she's not dominant uh that's
true
they got like a fist fight though right
oh yeah does it say that chin
dude remember hope solo you remember
hope solo the goalie
that was [ __ ] everybody up for soccer
white girl
yeah yeah like the best ghost strawberry
she got suspended
wait wait she was just like she got
kicked off team she's just willing like
a man jeremy stevens who was a tight end
for the tampa bay buccaneers playing at
washington shout out to him yeah
they used to i mean she's big he's big
isn't it
straight up this is jj watt with the jj
watson with a soccer player he's a
soccer player
i did jj watch this show he got those
shoulders they're throwing stuff at each
other in the living room
oh that was it we couldn't get them
pulled apart oh damn
yeah there you go yeah that was it
that's good though much louder than much
love to them for working yeah
they still together well that's old yeah
that's old as [ __ ] yeah that's an old
five years ago they're probably watching
this show why are you bringing up oh
[ __ ] man
yeah they're [ __ ] yeah white freaking
oh is it okay the fighter brought it up
not
everyone he brought it up you really
yeah i did
yeah i did the responsibility gonna fall
on you though brilliant dude how about
how about in our text that i told you
we're bb
bb m's yeah bb beautiful men because
they got the bbws with bbm
yeah cause because our friend got a bbw
on his line he kinda
she's egyptian he caught a dick
on the line and he was like yeah
everyone knows i like bbws i went well
yeah we bbms we bbm
me chappelle and jay are bbn but jay
trying to act like he and bbm
that's what i i said how long we gonna
pretend in this chat
that jay skinny how long we gonna
pretend i swear he's the thickest
one he's the thickest [ __ ] kid out of
all of us
he's talking about now you get my body
fight the only thing
he's doing his body fat he texts me too
he goes damn dawg i did my body fat they
said i'm only 20
i don't know right
you look skinny there though no there's
one look at that boy
big he's the thickest one brendon when
you said he had thirty percent
i went you're 30. he did you're 30. you
did 30
you gave the man 30 he's every bit of 30
percent
oh yeah that's the best picture he said
me stevie and uh
uh and him that were swollen patrol yeah
he was like yo okay how long are you
gonna pretend that you're skinny
he acts like we don't see it
bbm y'all a bbm shout out to
blackberries blackberry bbm big
beautiful man
big beautiful man how do you feel about
it is that is that a uh oh the phone
remember the blackberry and they had the
bbm
thing have to send like it's like that
oh yeah
yeah exactly hey is bbm a uh uh genre on
uh like you porn i feel like it should
be what i doubted it
why are we searching this bbm porn
that's why let me go to a different
search engine so i don't know is this
allowed mess up my stuff oh it's allowed
yeah
i thought i thought we were a commercial
okay bb emmy a big beautiful man i would
assume
that they're pretty right i don't know
i've never heard
of like i'm not about to look at no drug
dealers i made it up
what does bbm mean okay big beautiful
women no bbm bbm
i know that's it said that's what it
means chappelle and jr bbm's
big beautiful men see if something pops
up instead big beautiful man i don't
think that i don't think that's a saying
i don't think people know this is the
same food make it up yeah i think you
just did i think we made it up
bb and shout out to let's look at the
urban decay i know there's a nation of
bb
you know that's bbw says
god damn but there's not too uh it says
is this allowed
i don't there isn't anything and there's
no big dudes
no big dude oh my god that is a big
[ __ ] yeah
okay all right that's enough yeah yeah
that thing was
that was cool hey i hate how you i hate
how you in text
by the way i i i i little i gave you all
a secret this weekend
gave me all this what was your secret
you did you did some uh you did some
back in my dark bbw
heavy lifting oh no man that was
you said you wanted her to sit on your
face bro you would die
that was that was you died big black men
oh that's what it stands for big black
well
now man bbm is big beautiful man
yeah but uh oh but behaviorally bisexual
oh no man no wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait no
of our acronym yeah alex in a picture
i can 320 pounds that's actually more
than that you're more than oh really
probably more than that yeah yeah
good for you this sbb well back in my
dark days so what is it
like what what like you just all that
you like all that
well here's the there's a lot it was a
lot and i'm not saying your picture
it's a lot well i was i was skinnier
like you remember that picture you said
on the airplane yeah you was
you were so skinny in that picture i was
skinny in that picture right so
and she if she was sitting on this couch
it'd have been like she just came about
right here
right all right okay cool so she came
out of nowhere i'm not scared of
anything
you know my dad told me never be afraid
of nothing in life sure that's a saying
so when she came up to me and she was
like yo i want you
to like get in me and i was nervous a
little bit she said get in me get in me
so i never dealt with like a mack truck
before
so yeah well my dad dropped 18 willis
back in the day come on so
um i was all right i'm gonna get in you
so here's the thing about messing with a
big woman
it's a smell that you're not used to
it's the way it is it's the stinky rolls
i didn't know what a big girl nope but i
i've watched enough 600 pound life to
know that they stink
bro so i'm thinking about all of them
i'm doing work it's just because of the
skin just chilling there bro
it's more than the skin though bro they
they she took a shower right before we
had sex right
so then bro i know and it's still the
smell but i didn't even know i didn't
have it in i'm making this face
i'm making love to creases ooh she
smells jesus
yes don't you smell like nervousness
crevices she smells like boston
she smells like boston market you know
when you that's just
that crap yeah exactly she was like yo
and i don't know what it was
yeah and here's the thing never let a
big girl like [ __ ] so i let her get on
top
let her ride oh you were struggling to
breathe
i'm last trying to get on top you know
how your legs go numb after three
seconds
yeah i was like i don't feel [ __ ] damn
is it good for you cause they [ __ ] for
me damn
yeah bruh she yeah in half and after she
got hers off and then
i was like all right i'd never do this
again and she was like hey when the next
time we're gonna do it yeah that that
text comedy sentence looked a little
different
i know right this one was awesome
yeah it looked like you came back yeah
right
right right i was like yeah you said i
missed you
what should i do too i didn't say i miss
you but here's the thing when a big one
now but if you get past the smell it's
like magic
really yeah it feels great because
they're not they're nice
they're not really nice big women pack
they pack like that extra wetness down i
respect it
hundred percent shout out to shout outs
good for you man yeah i had to take it
out but
now we're brothers because i had to
admit i had to get out of my chest and i
got a question i'm glad you did that
yeah 100
yeah because we all knew i'm saying that
yeah right yeah
he wasn't like oh wow man he didn't even
say that he did it but it was an
obvious based off the messages he was
like i said do you feel better now
we all know i was holding that in
because y'all was teasing my man the
whole time i'm like you know
we light justin yeah he rolls with it
though he rolls with him he loves it
but i couldn't i was like those are his
queens those are his queens yeah he said
he got one from the show
and i'm kind of big old egyptian queen
big you said a thick mummy oh
bro you call her a thick mother i said
dude let me get a pic send me a picture
of that thick ass mommy
i feel like i offended him he didn't
respond back
too much too much i was like god damn it
yeah these are fat mummies why you
google fat mummys
because it's a good question they
weren't really fat they didn't eat like
that
oh uh jake's sent in the text the
egyptian gods happy
uh they praised they like so back then
oh they praised they praised fat
fat egyptian god it meant you had money
right if you're fat back in the day yeah
in asia too yeah well buddha was fat
was he really yeah it's weird buddha
talking about discipline all this god
damn
go away go back go back go back oh look
you got a fake mummy casket
go to that one all the way to the right
god damn
you looking at your i don't know i'm not
like you got back huh
you can do that 100 and i love how she
said hello am vivian am fat and pumpy i
want to be hooked up
wait what oh gosh especially a little
bit
hooked up to the iv damn that girl's
skinny compared to what malek sent us
yeah
yeah yeah yeah i thought girls yeah no
you weren't skinny
bro i wish i could remember you i know i
wish i died
i was like legs in the jeans bro i was
like y'all respect me y'all respect me
of that i took that down
i had to bro skinny skinny listen to me
you're not going to see
anything i was like like you don't even
like
just listen just give you a definition
type in sbbw
s what super big beautiful women yeah
look at this super that's a real thing
oh my god
i should have went to the other browser
yeah and all of them are skinnier than
one sheet
look at that
i should have went to a different
browser
oh my god you in that position you there
all right it feel like it's
it feel like they can only they can only
be with dudes with big wieners
well yeah yeah they feel like they feel
like a car seat it's science
only dog that picture brought back
memories oh dude how about your boy uh
dak prescott oh yeah you know what
happened for the season so let me let me
paint the narrative here so dak prescott
for the last five years has been
balling he hasn't won like playoff games
but he's ballin
he's definitely a franchise quarterback
so they he wanted a long-term deal they
kept
franchise tagging meaning you give them
one year salary
you get paid like 40 mil or 30 mil it's
a lot of money
but they don't invest long term so they
offered him a deal he turned it down so
they franchise tagged them
well franchise tag you get paid for that
one year but if you get hurt you're
[ __ ]
he threw for the most passing yards and
i think four games than any other
quarterback in
nfl history yesterday he had a compound
fracture on his ankle
blew his [ __ ] ankle out so it's like
is he is he out for the season excuse me
yeah dude so he lost all that money well
it's just like
it's so [ __ ] up because now jerry
jones and the
nfl is like well this is why this is why
we didn't give a long-term deal because
there's a chance to get hurt he's never
missed a game in his entire he never
missed a game
what he did his entire team banked on
him playing the season balling out then
getting to re-up and get a huge deal
like patrick mahomes or some of those
but do you think they offered him a
contract but he's not from a tasty
contract yeah but he didn't want to he
was like not
but now i i know he kind of regressed
that decision but i think
but but but you also post a bet on
yourself so he was probably i'mma ball
out this
year i i don't agree with it because it
sounds like in the deal they offered him
was like almost 100 million games
dude that's not a good deal yeah i
thought it was a good deal he wanted
like
he wanted like patrick mahomes yeah uh
it was great it was lots
of sean watson money he's not getting
that it's the dallas cowboys i know he's
not look here it is
five years 175 million extension
he turned it down he turned it down
that's crazy so he should have went with
that 100.
so now but yeah
blew out your ankle now it's like if
you're the dallas cowboys you're like
this is why we it's so [ __ ] up like
that's why we do this
well now do you think like like gm's and
and owners you think like down they're
gonna be more cautious
on like a lot of let's just throw
patrick mahomes out the way right he's
no one's getting that deal but let's say
like a lamar jackson who's looking for a
new deal or
uh deshawn watson or sean watson got a
good deal right he got paid you desean
watson is actually making more money
than patrick mahomes
patrimo homes is over 10 years dude
where it's a
500 but it's over 10 years but 10 years
deshawn watson's making more money how
much does this do his is a shorter deal
like five or six years but he's actually
making more money in those six years
than deshawn watson's making i mean you
pet your moms yeah sorry
damn but it just for for for dak
prescott i'm not you know i i don't
dislike him
he's just whatever to me but whatever it
shows you the gnarly side of sports
it's that's how that i cheered man ain't
no kind of money in there like that it's
so [ __ ] up it was [ __ ] up
his injury was he was crying on the
field oh
he was crying the injuries you can break
it up go to trying to see that
i'm not trying you should go to dax
prescott uh injury
dak prescott i know right cats already
like
some of those stuff i can't watch
depends that little lady you can just
tell by the second video
which means the bone broke out of the
skin oh it popped out
i don't want to watch it what happened
did he get sacked he got tackled
and his ankle decided to
right here right here oh
look he calls out like right away he
calls over he's like oh [ __ ]
oh it's twisted around but it broke out
oh how about how about tony roman goes
you gotta hope it's a cramp
a cramp i didn't hear anything all right
all right jen i saw it i mean he wants
to see the reaction
tony roman said yeah you gotta hope it
do you want to see reaction from look at
him crying crying
that's how you know it was game over oh
he's crying because he's in pain
no he's crying because he's like he the
gamble didn't work out
was like this is exactly what it when
his team sat down
they went should we take the long-term
deal and they're like are you banking
herself you ball out when you get the
biggest contract ever
but you know you can't get hurt and he's
like dude i've never been hurt i've
never missed a game
i'll bank on that well it was a tough
season for him anyway his brother died
in this past offseason his brother
committed suicide committed suicide
yeah um morgan his mama died his mom
died previously and now he was just
i think it was accumulation of this
injury it hurt him pain
and all his i should have took that but
you can't listen he better on himself
this is what this is the bad side of it
this is why it's just so what happens to
what he
i mean he's out for the rest of the year
he's gonna
recover and then it's like dallas isn't
gonna sign a long-term deal now yeah
yeah
he's hurt so it's like he's probably
just getting regular quarterback money
i don't know i don't know what they're
going to do i don't know and then if
they start winning with andy dalton
their backup who's legit they won
yesterday
if they even do they want to so that
happened early in the game that happened
and then
back up andy dalton who was a starter
for a long time for the banks came in
and won oh wow so that that actually if
they go on a winning streak and he does
well
i bet dax never plays with dallas again
he'll get picked up by some other team
hopefully the broncos that's the sad
thing about sports someone always in a
cut
waiting it's kind of like like
relationships well dude think about
explain
okay well not with super bbws but
[Laughter]
la chargers right okay uh i think it's
uh
taylor gerard taylor right was the
starter
was the straight up starter the running
back the quarterback
injured his ribs and in order to play
yeah in order to play the game that to
give him a shot in the ribs so he could
go on playing
the doctor went to give him a shot right
before the game
went too far punctured his lung mm-hmm
so
that's the gameplay then homeboy who
they drafted with the first pick you
know
about the white guy he was on um all uh
hbo's he played for oregon white boy
yeah yeah
super baller yeah young guy he was in a
precinct so i don't know what to expect
from him
while they're warm-ups yeah justin
herbert
played for oregon tall he's like six six
stud so he they obviously drafted him to
be the starter but
they they promised tyrod tyrod taylor he
would get a fair shot at starter
so he earns the job because there's no
preseason yeah they're saying the rookie
he's just not ready yeah he's not ready
to play the dude knows that the homeboy
is waiting in the wings
andrews ribs he's like i don't want to
go out give me a shot doctors cool story
punctures his lung while they're warming
up they tell her
herbert hey dude you're the starter he
balls out
throws for 400 yards and then tie rods
ready to go and they're like
sorry dude that's for the football field
400 yards
yeah it's crazy numbers for crazy
numbers he's threw for like 300 i think
but either way played good
and then this next game balled out again
and they were like
yeah this is our starter now if you're
tyrod taylor like hold the
hold up dude i didn't lose my job
because i played bad i didn't lose my
job
because i made an error i lost my job
because this doctor
yeah [ __ ] hit me in the liver dude
get that money the nflpa would go after
him okay but but it's like
they'll go after him and he'll get
compensated like he was the starter for
that one year
but then it's like you're [ __ ] dude
it's so [ __ ] sports just
professional sports in any level are so
[ __ ] it's so cutthroat
because tyrod taylor like yeah dude what
page yeah that does that's nothing to
them
damn it's gig over
[ __ ] i know it's messed up is it [ __ ]
up
also i want to change i want to change
topics a little bit did you read
about the kidnapping of the michigan gov
governor
oh they're the plot together and the
no it's a woman the captain of the the
captain of the
uh you you don't see any of this huh
i saw that look i was like hold on look
and and the captain of the police team
was in on it too yeah so i'm saying he
was like yo citizens arrest how would
you want to
like what well they still doing
kidnappings in 2020 well they didn't do
it they tried
they wanted to and here's both two of
them had marine backgrounds gee
yeah it was 13 of them yeah you could
just tell
kidnapper you got piercing blue eyes
though let's call it what it is
wait he's okay so he tried to they uh
13. there's dublin ohio didn't know
there's a dublin ohio
suburban ohio two weeks earlier after
exchanging messages online
for certain extreme messages online uh
it was about three months into the
shutdowns forced by spread of
coronavirus
they're frustrated yeah because
michigan's uh this is
[ __ ] north korea uh but fox 11 wanted
to get a step further
uh and they talked about killing tyrants
and taking a governor they reached out
to some armed groups
to add manpower including members of the
local armed group called the wolverine
watchmen oh
wow what a cool name watchmen
wolverine the watchmen have been flagged
as a guy in march
and one of its members was now a snitch
oh one of the
others on the inside as well undercover
operators recorders allowed the bureau
to monitor
so they were going to suffer in that
thing or what no so what they had is
they were stuck they were stalking the
vacation home of a crib right they was
going to detonate a bomb over there to
throw the police off
so they all go over there they go over
there and go to her home
but i wanted to ask you a question so
her and trump
like trump and her have been sneak this
in each other throughout the whole the
beginning
oh wait word yeah okay so much love i
thought she was more direct like 50.
but uh okay yeah you're right okay so so
trump caller the woman of michigan and
called her half winfield like her last
name is what whitfield right
and he was like yo she's half with phil
like she's not even a
full human being so these guys they were
like yo
they of course how she handled the
pandemic she was like i don't want any
corona outbreak
i would take and they was like uh they
stormed early in the year with arm
gun like armed military guns to like uh
what is it the national um
what where where did they storm the
capital the capital not the capital but
her name is whitmore just whitmer i mean
yeah whitman um
what are you looking for now i was
looking for what did they say they
stormed earlier this year
because she was being uncivilized about
how she was going to handle the
uh she shut down like all like
businesses like she's
she's similar to california oh [ __ ]
she's brutal dude
oh damn she and she's very and she's
democratic
and the house of uh the republican that
was like yo
they were mad that she didn't tell them
about the plot they didn't let her in
they was like well we got death threats
too they was trying to kick that me too
oh
[ __ ] yeah and he he was like so there's
it's beef it's a
it's like eco west coast beef corn oh
like oh gee east coast west coast beef
100 yeah talking big huh i was doing
some kind of i was doing
she came out yeah you bro science that
whatever
[Laughter]
that was my report this weekend i know
right thanks for that [ __ ] report
report was all over i know i'm trying to
just try to follow he's like in whitman
yeah yeah what more could you be the
worst [ __ ] daily news
what is happening
[Applause]
no not up in here and then and then
they're like they're throwing
shade at each other
like we used to go west coast wait i
like going it was like this one
hit us with today's
you can never make fun of chin's current
event
and then trump and then trump didn't
like her
and then they stormed the battle you
know you heard about the republicans
yeah
he's like it's like crips and blood
one's blue one's red
yeah have you seen the vietnam war
i love how y'all trying to follow me i
was like bro
i don't know
don't worry about that look i got it
look bro solid man
and then i was like don't worry about it
and the woman was like
no not today and then they try to they
try to put a bomb yeah they started
putting
vacation home yeah they try to detonate
a dead native bomb
to distract the cops and you remember
two of them was a marine
two they were marines
i can't remember when they were rings or
i don't know if they're still acting
but here's it
we're gonna do that and then they're
gonna kidnap her but she didn't have her
kids with her they were like
at the grandparents so it was just her
and her husband oh what is happening
right now hold on wait hold on you know
you remember that little
kid that was trying to tell a story a
little he
[Applause]
[Applause]
we study this guy right here that would
go down to the phone
he was like i fired him when i knew
because i have an army background
i knew something he was up to something
so i just let him go
i was like how do you know but you could
just tell you're still gonna run with it
huh i know right yeah
just give it up give it up what did this
guy come into the [ __ ]
he hired the guy yeah right where did he
work
they got all types of vacuums they got
the ones with the water in it
dude tell a story and he just move out
all the important details he's like yeah
so look i was locked up with a boy right
and he looked man nah bruh what you just
did he pulled out the gun and then
whooped
we hear whoops
listen guys you get judged off your
underwear these days
i know you're like what i still got
these old whitey tighties with the
peepee stains in the front
stop doing that man get you some me
undies all right get me undies man
get them they're undies they're grown on
trees seriously they're made from
crazy soft natural fiber source from
beechwood trees
you know what natural fiber means that
their micro modal
is not only super soft but breathable
light
and crazy comfy alright everything
meundies does
to help you feel truly comfortable from
head to toe from outside to inside
whatever you want to do step up your
comfy game with a new nine-inch boxer
brief with
a fly to prevent rolling or reduce
chafing it's a win-win
never run out of undies this is what i
do they got a meundies membership
every month i get a new pair of undies
straight to my door
i save money they got cool halloween
ones which i really dig right now my
kids dig
halloween prints buy me undies like
bloodsuckers scaredy cats funny bones
meundies has an offer for you guys for
the first time purchasers you get 15
off and free shipping me undies also has
problem free philosophy if you're not
satisfied with any product for any
reason they will refund or exchange it
no caveats no questions asked you get
your money back but you're
not going to need to do that because
these are the best underwear on the
planet
to get your 50 off and free shipping go
to meundies.com
fighter that's meundies.com fighter
well in other news we're talking about
uh bill burr on saturday night live
oh yeah that's a current event went hard
in the paint went hard in the painting
but it's bill being bill that's right
people know these woke dummies who are
like how can you allow this guy inside
our lives like
oh you don't know about bill bill burr
like that's bill burr being bill burke
that's what's fantastic about it i feel
like people
give other people too much credit for
why they're upset
it's like [ __ ] chill relax it's some
jokes
one headline i saw is jokes and but his
intense
jokes and his intent is to rile you
dummies up yeah and and
look what they do they do exactly what
he what what he says they do
they do exactly that what he said who
told bill burr he's a straight white man
should try to tackle homophobia and
racism in the worst way possible in this
snl monologue i had to turn off after
five minutes you gave it five minutes
damn
it the monitor was only the amount of
logs was like seven minutes
you lasted that long but you know what
you know what's so funny whenever
people they people pick out [ __ ] like he
said a bunch of stuff
but they only pick and choose what
because you know what they're mad about
exactly that it's like well okay and i'm
like listen
people can get offended that's the they
have people are
monologue and then tweeting how upset
you are about it
that's hilarious if one of you guys did
that you wouldn't be here on monday i
swear
if anybody in this room did that i'd be
like dude we can't have you around yeah
you're right we just can't you can't
exactly you can't be part of the group
you can't can't you like a youtube
comment at that yeah and
these people act like bill burr owe them
something what does he owe you [ __ ]
nothing but what you do
him talk about and being upset that
that's exactly his point of the
monologue yeah this is yeah
how white women hijacked this woke
movement and the black lives matter so
funny so funny he goes and they saw that
him do that the champions are
over right before the pandemic cabin i
saw him do it at the comedy store
it's great oh it's so great in this take
on the first lady
it's so funny yeah so [ __ ] funny
but it's bill bird being bill burke yeah
so it's like the only people that are
upset are people that don't know bill
burst you don't know um
you don't know anything about it but
you've never heard of them never heard
of them and you're not gonna be fans
anyway so you suck
and then the other people who like it
are his fans anyway so
it didn't really it's just like yeah it
does it does it's a win-win for bill
yeah it's a win-win
but also what they say he took a page
out of louis ck's
uh book there because louis c.k has been
doing saturday live
hot take monologues for a hot second
you're seeing lucy
on there he's probably done it four
times oh and every time it's a hot take
that
riles everybody up everybody talks about
it and they keep booking them
it's just what but it's what to me
what's dope about it
is it's authentic right it's like that
and saturday live knows booking bill
burr like you're getting you know
they know what they're going to get he's
not going to tailor it towards yeah he's
like he's going to give you bill burr
and he killed it like all this he could
get it was funny
right the boston lager one yes it was
like him
yes but by the way the dinner when they
kept mispronunciating the words
so yeah people get riled up you know
what'd you do this weekend um i've been
uh binge watching a bunch of stuff i've
been watching american horror story and
i started blind manor
blind man is good right it's good i'm on
like the third or fourth i'm on third
it's really never heard of it so far
it's the second season to
uh haunting house but you don't need to
watch the first series
oh you don't like scary scenes i don't
know it's not scary it's more like
suspense
i feel like it's not exactly scary but i
don't think it's like scary the way like
a slasher would you be scared
if you're like goat like chill on that
planet like ghost stuff
like ghost stuff like it's ghost stuff
yeah it's very
my girl went on a date night on thursday
night and then i knew that i knew we
were like in west hollywood
and we were driving home late and she's
kind of into the same [ __ ] i am i go you
know the manson murder happened over
here
she's like no it didn't i go look up
ceelo drive she's like what [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
we're only two miles away from like you
want to go she's like no i'm like say no
more
so we drove that doesn't sound like
y'all
it's just like i i was like bring it
bring up the the house on your phone
that's the house wait they still have it
up
no that one's the lost felis house
that's the where the second murders
happened
this one's obvious but i think it's 2500
killing anyone like physically no he
talked these dummies into doing it
yeah but yet they label him a serial
killer doesn't make sense
can't be a trans that's the real house
that's where's that house at
ceelo drive in hollywood uh it's off
sunset that's a beautiful
he had that that was his house it's a
beautiful house what no
sharon stone lived there the famous
action sharon tate bro sharon tate and
he murdered her
there and the other people inside one
was the she was gorgeous
i loved god you love hot well
i love the look yeah i love you you love
it all right love you
more time could you live in that like
let's say you're shopping for a
house and someone's like yeah sharon
tate was murdered here but
but now it doesn't look like that now
they knocked it down they remodeled its
brand new house well i mean could you
live there yeah they knocked it down
remodeled it i've been to kurt cobain's
house they knocked down that um
um what uh what the defense no
where where uh he killed himself that
he was definitely and kurt cobain
definitely murdered yeah that's all
another story but i definitely
that's a conspiracy theory i love the
that one's easy
what the hell was it called was it
called a greenhouse or something the
love the black house or
back house or something where where it
came down they tore that down
it was like people there's like an
addict in there people live there i've
been there i
went to the house there's so many people
that come and uh just do it in that
that house greenhouse that area where
where his house is
don't [ __ ] where's kirk cobain yeah
it's on
lake washington it is beautiful
and they have like a memorial bench just
right outside the um
that one's pretty easy to solve that
one's not really you figured it out you
a detective now
um i could be you know they reopened the
case they did not reopen
why would they reopen that case knowing
they [ __ ] up
yeah that was a dope house definitely
haunted but no
you would live there i would there's
people that live there right now i was
about to say
i'm sure there are i'm asking would you
live there me chapelle lacy yes
uh yeah are you you could live in the
sharon tate house the insurance hey
house it's a great house they rebuilt it
it's not the same house it's called the
love house here's the thing you got to
know it's tight
but here's the thing you got to deal
with is there's people like my dumbass
every night of the year driving up there
right there yeah there's tons
of people there can you name a more
famous murder site than sharon tate
man besides dallas jfk name
no uh-uh that's pretty dude when i went
there
for sure but he commits suicide there to
the public so it's like all right he did
it himself not a big deal
but sharon tate was murdered by the
manson family what about the doctor that
killed michael jackson in
his house in beverly hills i don't think
he owned that house he didn't own it
i don't think he owned that house i
don't think that was beverly hills that
was off
no that would be that'd be encino no no
no
that was the two houses right that was a
house when they were kids
well he did own that house he lit
literally he homby hills
that's calabasas isn't it isn't it i
thought it was better
that would be right outside uh like
hollywood
could you live in that house yeah would
you live in canada that michael jackson
no no no no could you hell yeah because
if you can afford that house
why would you live there true out of all
the houses and and
and i got kids so every time like the
the hollywood stars
tour stops there every stop oh yeah it's
like yeah
why the [ __ ] are these fans yeah that's
gonna be real annoying yeah you're right
i was a giant house
that's a giant house that's a mansion
wouldn't live i think the biggest house
uh eddie probably andy murphy's
not even more than likely have you been
there no i've seen it on i
i wouldn't buy michael jackson's house
no i wouldn't buy the house that's just
too negative
the little boy [ __ ] god no yeah that was
uh neverland
the sacrament is everywhere
neverland is still up they no one can no
one no one's bought it
i don't think anyone is going to buy
this it's just too damn expensive yeah
but also
make that like a a museum please
something yeah make it uh amusement park
something just look at it look at this
no okay oh yeah you're right i see what
you're learning
looks like disneyland yeah yeah look
great like sam said make it some kind of
cute
for the kids huge again i apologize
my bad i'm making something for kids
making something for kids
that's what it's for though yeah that's
what i'm saying that's why he built it
for kids so kids would come around he
was climbing
he used to climb trees he's a weird
[ __ ] dude let's just call it what it
was
i mean i think but that's the thing like
because he has so much money and so much
fame did he become weird over the time
or you just like always had that in it
because he didn't have a child about how
they grew up i mean he didn't have all
of his dads yeah his dad he was like
also and he was saying that he's white
and he said
that no he had the skin disease he had
lego and then he bleached everything
right is that what he did yes i think
that's i know he had the video
story how do you say it rogan has that
i have on his hands yeah you got it yeah
yeah i have it on my back
oh really it's very light do i have it
i just thought i was ashy do i have it
no no you're just ashy
yeah michael dude talk about i mean
who's done that kind of transition
what do you mean sammy as a human well
sammy salsa i mean
there's a lot of mental health issues
there from the oh all
the plastic surgeries
i mean he would say he got it the worst
out of his uh
siblings because he was the most dad
like their dad being hard on them
he looks terrible i know those surgeries
made him look awful
yeah he was such a hair when he hung his
baby outside the window in france
yeah yeah
how's blanket doing anybody check up on
that probably not good dude
i didn't know i wanted it's like what
he's got paris paris paris
paris be talking [ __ ] online she sticks
up for her dad she sticks up for her
daddy i like that
you expect her not to no i'm just saying
the the one in the second picture in the
chicago jersey he used to come to the
gracie academy all the time
the what the gracie academy did you do
academy oh
i thought it was like something
completely tough because they're not
are any of them blood related are they
all
i think they all have the same mom yeah
the woman i think that's what's her name
yeah
i think she lives out like lancaster
right yeah
i know what her name is damn what was
her name it doesn't matter
the thing is it's it's all a [ __ ] show
yeah it is all the [ __ ] [ __ ] all of
it yeah
debbie rowe debbie rowe
young dead debbie cakes
debbie cakes very weird and did they
artificially inseminate her like they
didn't have
i don't even know if i don't know i
don't know what to think i know
what do you think is
is it sperm or anything you don't think
it says or anything no
you don't think those kids are his like
no no you don't think that i think he
was too good to like
like have sperm in women as i say like
i didn't want to get like vulgar on this
podcast but i think like yo it's not his
kids obviously we're all thinking
and i think that this guy like michael
jackson didn't not he didn't have orgasm
isn't there a rumor that like when he
was young his dad
had him castrated so like his voice
would stay
really high really yeah they had been a
documentary
really that's a rumor that's like a long
time rumor do you see the documentary
with those two dudes
which one no i'm not buying that [ __ ]
either i think you don't buy it i think
they're all
the white guy who lied oh no i don't say
that the two dudes
the two dudes one's a dancer one was a
choreographer one was a dancer before
that documentary came out
he went to the michael jackson family
and asked if he could be the
choreographer for the show in uh las
vegas and they told him no
then he was like okay [ __ ] this and then
when went bad on him
you know really i don't believe either
of those two i think they're both
[ __ ] no you know he's never been
convicted listen i don't know what goes
down with him
there's obviously some issue with kids
there yeah um
but you know he's never been
convicted of child abuse right sexually
abusing children ever yeah
wow he settled out of court with most of
them
but i think you think they just wanted
money most of them yeah but you had that
manner of like him
every time we look at michael jackson
we're like yo he's the greatest biggest
pop star ever but
also play with children they just have
that like you know i mean
here's the here's the thing though and
again i'm not a big conspiracy guy but a
lot of that news about him touching kids
came out
after he got all the masters of the
beatles and all the masters of
oh yeah he owned all of it you know what
that is a conspiracy
he owned a big part of sony sony music
or something like that right he owned
all his masters think how much that is
yeah and then all the beatles master
exactly the biggest band in the world
he still does i think i think paul
mccartney is trying to get it back he
sold it
look before he paid like 40 million for
it and then got like
sold it for like 600 million did you
know before he died he was working and
training for the big a billion dollar
tour did y'all yeah
how much did he sell it for like like
400 subs
600 it's crazy yeah so it was a great
interview
he owned all those masters on his own
and all the [ __ ] about the kids came out
after that
they're like oh really
i don't get i don't get what that why
they would put that on him because he
owned those masters well because it's
all money like
the beatles couldn't too much power yeah
they couldn't he couldn't play his music
he couldn't play the beatles hey mike
can you play the beatles nah
okay that's like oh [ __ ] bro you own
much power yeah
no one man should have all that is that
what kanye says that's what i think yeah
then you know kanye wants to have all
his masters put a whole concept that's
the thing that a lot of those cats do i
mean jay-z has all his doesn't he
no jay-z just bought his or oh he's just
brought his
is tough because he says he wants all
his masters yet he renegotiates several
contracts
knowing he's playing the game and then
he has his own label good music
he doesn't let those artists own their
own masters what are you talking about
do the same with prince prince owned all
his too
and that's the way you have to go right
now in the music industry because
let's say your stuff don't sell like a
lot of these already signed 360 deals
meaning that like yo okay if whatever
we'll promote you we'll put the battery
in your back
right we'll promote all your songs on
the radio all the spotify
all the endorsements but we get all that
money back you get your money on tour
that's a 360 deal
yes damn like justin bieber makes most
his money
not from releasing singles that's just
marketing he makes all his money off
the road selling merch that's where most
his money comes from
but that's why you're trying to on the
road wow well that's aggressive music
like they don't make that much so what
professional sports music
that's where you can get entertainment
industries where you get just [ __ ]
over
look at stand up look at i mean a lot of
it dude you know
but you don't get popular it's super
super hard to get popular unless you do
that
like you know the bands i work with
let's show the backgrounds yeah once
once they
signed with the label they were
everywhere they got songs on uh tv shows
they got songs
on commercials but before then they were
awesome but no
you got to play but you got to play the
game yeah you got to play the game
damn mm-hmm and it's kind of like
it's messed up it's dark yeah it's dark
speaking of dark louisiana is having
like
a hurricane uh laura going on right now
really
you didn't even know that my people at
home and it was like bro but it's not
hitting them that bad right
yeah they hit him i saw one death and
that was like 90. well i'm talking about
like a lot of people
trying to like stay and try to fight
like nah get up out of there how do you
fight a hurricane
a lot of people just a lot of people
bunker down they don't think you're that
bad
when it gets bad it's too late and
they're [ __ ] they just got power
on in lake charles this week oh they
just got power on yep
guys killing six now six is too many
it's politicians to say one is too many
six too many but six
brendan what are you doing wait bro what
are you doing for a natural disaster sis
that is yeah you're right you can't
ditty bop over the fact that
yeah i'm following you thank you
appreciate you bro
i thought i was by myself over there
look i'll repeat it
for you i got your back i'm i'm saying
hey diddy
there you go copy that look so i'm
saying okay six people it's
terrible but louisiana let's be honest
they're still trying to recover from
hurricane katrina that's how he got here
yeah that's how i came yeah but i'm not
a refugee my dad was like yeah yeah
so um i'm saying now lake charles like
of course they're fatigued they're
emotionally drained like no one is
helping his non-national attention
and they told me to talk about that on
the pod there you go okay
oh that's why you brought it up yeah
well melanie you're doing great yeah
that was better than the [ __ ]
kidnapping story well just tell me on
the phone
that was it yeah you did that one really
good what happened with the [ __ ]
kidnapping i don't like
all over the board i was you know what
group projects they was like you know
like the teachers
so someone was like hey man can you
bring light to the hurricane
they see you know malik's gonna have
like these dude for
4.99
in a group project i just showed up
that's all it is
we got it we got our stuff together
you're the guy at the end
that says does anyone have any questions
any questions
what if he hit us with that brendan what
you guys got any questions
use your eight parts of speech i had a
couple of prepositional phrases yes
current event i respect it you you threw
it out i threw it out there bruh
you know what else was he gonna do shoot
her shoot me i mean i'm mad because me
and my girl really went over that she
was like bae and this girl was telling
you what to say
she was like babe make sure you mention
that they had a bomb
in a vacation home i don't know you got
to get detailed
you never get too much into it man
she believed in me man you and your
queen y'all do [ __ ] y'all hang out y'all
ready
oh no course this weekend i invited
y'all over and then it was a
laughingstock
first i don't even know how to [ __ ]
play it wait what you don't know how to
play uno no
i don't play games pretty good yeah oh
what'd you do
i went to arizona visited yeah visiting
my nephew and stuff
six hour drive no it's not uh it's like
a what is that
five and a half that's not bad yeah it's
not bad at all
arizona's nice there's such a short
flight though such a short flight
i'd rather drive because i hate flying
but such a short flight
so yeah i call him my nephew but that's
my uh my best friend that passed away i
got an emotional
son yeah i got emotional yeah bro salute
bruh yeah
so we've been uh ever since his dad
passed we've just been
really connecting and keeping that's me
right there that's cool look at that
tongue though love it
you gotta kiss tongue i know that's
that's real too i know what's he do out
there
uh how old is he he's uh 14 what yeah he
just got into dive
so he i went to his dive practice
because he wanted to show me
because because he knows i do all the
flipping it's cool oh yeah because they
do a ton of flavors yeah yeah so he's he
was excited to show me uh
are you are you on the road this week
mm-hmm you're in tampa this way tampa
tampa tampa tampa florida's wide open
though
they're wide open wide open they are
wide open personnel it's wide open yep
you leave thursday mm-hmm why are you
looking at me crazy
just saying tampa ebor right what's evor
eboard's the little uh
city area it's in downtown tampa
seaboard see i didn't know that oh
with the yvonne yeah eboard city yeah
yeah
yeah terrence ross is gonna come through
oh shout out to you magic that's cool
yeah he's going him and his wife are
going to come down
that'd be cool yeah big shout out to him
three point specialists
shout out to danny green tampa or
florida's the only state that's like
full-on
open huh isn't texas open florida no
texas
lifted to 70 when we were there
they just uh my girl was saying that my
home girl was saying that they just
lifted to
70 ours was 85 sure you think so
i know so how do you know so
because they pay me based off ticket
sales and i know the ticket sales i'll
give you that
come on i'm a humble stuff texas a
little open
florida indiana there's some other ones
open
indiana india's open really yeah what
i mean arizona i mean arizona is
basically open yeah yeah
where was i i mean everyone's messed up
i think do you think after the election
everyone's gonna be like
all right let's open it up hopefully the
world health organization came out and
said lockdowns were a bad idea
how do you know oh you read the news
they posted it right it wasn't
the whole article did they really say
that yeah they're like it's doing more
harm than good and also they're like
we never said you should be locked down
this long like lockdowns were made so
hospitals don't get overcrowded and once
you level that out you should release
everyone and
people go back to business but you just
you just do it so the
hospitals don't get overcrowded once
that happens you should be open
yeah we're not saying shut down for six
months you [ __ ] idiots
because you're talking about starvation
domestic violence
mental health yeah so people go broke oh
people have been going crazy yeah world
health is like this isn't what we're
telling you guys to do
where can i read that at i'll send you a
link
um yeah i'm always interested because
there's so much like
on both sides where it's just like the
information it just seems so
flip-flopping but if the who world
health organization or the cdc
post something that's pretty they're i
mean during pandemic they
some stuff was unknown but if they say
that then they got their [ __ ]
really pretty dialed in before we do
current events let me take a piss jim
sure
what are you doing with uh tiger and
boston for halloween now that like
i have a party at the house oh we got a
jumpy castle turning a hot that's good
oh that's gonna be fun
is he walking yet uh yes
kind of kind of yeah it's going to be
dope we have these little
little that's awesome there you go you
know where the costumes are going to be
yeah we're uh we're the mario family so
boston's little mario tigers luigi
um wifey is uh peach princess peach and
i'm wario
wario we're that fishy purple bro that's
so verbal look around look at it go to
the first one chin
yeah there we are damn you're going to
kill it as well already
oh yeah i hate that damn game but bruh
who's going to be the monster hey mario
gotta suck at it oh okay it's a it's a
me thing it has to do with me not with
mario
i'm glad i got no beef with him that's
how i am man hey i know when i
don't like something or upset it has to
do with me it's on you yeah
shout out to accountability i gotta help
you
okay so a bunch of people talk i got
that too
listen so people are saying that this is
chappelle
uh this was sent in from asano and matt
adams on instagram
i i'll just watch it
like this
[Music]
and all of a sudden i have like a bunch
of notifications yeah like
like a bunch and i'm like what the hell
is going on
and then i noticed it was the same thing
that people were tagging me and so then
i watched the video i was like
they got [ __ ] they got it got me
they got you guys everyone kept going
you okay
i love i i love the comments i wonder
what happened dude i'm gonna pray for
you
like i was just kidding do we know what
happened to him he feels probably i i
guarantee he's fine
he's fine that big boy hey what was he
thinking
he floated you know what honestly play
it again he thought he was going to land
8.9 like i never thought he was going to
land it was that was just
[ __ ]
[Applause]
oh my god
why is this big ass on that little
scooter anyways i feel like he used to
do this when he was younger
and weighed less and he was like i still
got it
listen i know my [ __ ] lane i know how
much i weigh oh my god i know what i can
do straight up back flips
all day anything else no yeah hold on
dude
go back to that he just pulled his feet
down
hold on because his feet were behind him
so that's what slowed him down
i love like how he's like about to go
into the flipping he was like
though yeah you know he's probably
landed that before
you can tell by the confidence look at
the ride
one of those rams yeah that's scary yeah
you know what i'm saying
do they have this homie's instagram i
bet it's via dxo
oh
duty i was i knew he was legit there's
no way
yeah oh he go that boy
yeah yes wait hold on you fell again oh
you show you the falls and then he show
you
oh look at that damn he's nice with it
he's so nice with it
damn nice bro i have to follow this dude
let me see what else he has what's his
instagram it's uh
they call him underscore dot patchy
with he's in uk where he's killing oh
he's in the uk please read that
shout out to the uk x dot underscore dot
patchy y
i love you got the smiley face in his
name that's why he didn't post him
busting his ass
no i know right he didn't post that
people people love to post i hope he's
okay
dude would it kill you to lose some
weight though bro let him know let him
have it don't have it
you don't have it would be better it's a
lot more uh come on he's probably better
than most people
yeah on a scooter most people can't do
what he's doing
look how he's look how he's whipping
that scooter he's whipping that's dumb
wait see if they should see if you post
this fall nah because you know why
they scream your failures but wish for
your no i bet you i bet you yeah he's
had to post that
this one is june 2019 so it would have
to be
all the way no scroll no scroll it's one
of those things that probably
could possibly resurface yeah because i
think yeah that's probably okay
now he didn't post it no that looks like
the same skate park
he been fought like he's like man i've
been falling all this time now y'all
gonna post this
this guy's a king mm-hmm this guy's a
[ __ ] king
i like him bro i respect him all the way
bro don't lose your weight maybe
yeah if you big and you still killing me
bro
in this way and that's impressive right
come on now he's 18 though he has a lot
of living to do
he does yeah but he's i'm just saying
that he's at that fearless mode 18
you're fearless
but that's why i'm saying i wonder how
far he can take it if he were to get
real serious
wait they had this he probably loses
weight from just doing that
they have scooter in the ice game he's
probably gonna yeah i don't think so i
don't know i don't think
not that mini scooter no they don't have
that i like this guy though yeah i
respect them all the way
yeah i got tagged so many still getting
tagged
he was just saying nothing's funny one
guy when people attack somebody when
that guy's in the line at walmart oh god
wait wait i didn't see that wait this is
my last week
yeah some black dude singing there's a
little blonde guy behind him everyone
thought was theo
yeah oh yeah someone thought that yeah
super
far right yeah oh yeah here's another
clip that we didn't bring up uh last
week
all right cat dude yeah there's another
one people tagged
me and you dude i got tagged in this one
too what is this
people won't leave me alone i get it i'm
thick but i'm not [ __ ]
that yeah but there's very oh
so he got it
oh what he found he blew his back back
out i look like that's what's going on
bro
this guy's comment goes okay we see you
as if we had a choice
[Laughter]
youtube comments i mean the uh instagram
for comments are the first [ __ ] it was
funny
damn it broke his spinal cord shouts out
to big homie though
i respect you and these bad dudes i know
dude i get technology you're not
fat yeah yeah i'm bbm yeah i'm bbi
don't get a twist yeah do not get that
[ __ ] twisted
so a catholic priest got arrested
along with two other women for having
sex at the
church altar because somebody walking
past by
saw two women starting to have sex
and then they reported it to the police
they kept watching and saw that the
father came in
and then started having sex with them
they were recording and the only reason
why they got arrested is because it was
in view of the public not because they
were [ __ ]
oh damn look at that [ __ ] look at
this yeah you think he wasn't gonna do
that come on
by the way how did he convince these two
girls to do it first of all
those two girls convinced them because
one of them is a dominatrix and then the
other one i think she is also a
sex worker i don't know what type
refresh my memory what's a dominatrix um
like clamps like leather like that
yes yeah you're like the girl who does
this you know what's weird is one's 23
wants 41.
tell me which one i have no idea yeah i
couldn't figure it out all in the
eyebrows but i can tell you
i i bet the one the one below
yeah look at her style
she she knows herself she's a little bit
more cleaned up a 23 year old would look
like that
this could be a scary movie skit yeah
homie
he looks terrible and i think catholic
priests aren't like supposed to have any
i don't even think they're allowed to be
married right yeah they're celibate
yeah mm-hmm yeah that's a lot he did
[ __ ] awesome
look at that guy come on dude yeah of
course he's gonna do who's going to
church and be like oh yeah he seems like
a good person
come on y'all listen to this dude what
else you got
so a couple of days ago vanessa hudgins
posted a photo onto instagram of her in
a cemetery and she captioned it
my happy place so vanessa hutchins is
very notorious for
posting throughout the month of october
because she loves halloween and she'll
post a bunch of like creepy [ __ ]
or like weird halloweeny type of stuff
and a lot of people
got mad at her because she posted a
photo in a cemetery saying that it was
her happy place
and people got mad at that what's wrong
with the world yeah what do you
[ __ ] get a lot of people said it was
disrespectful
did she show the names of the people no
these are just the photos who gives a
flying [ __ ]
right what happens if that's legit her
happy place
yeah how's that any different what does
that happen how's that any different
than posting on the san francisco bridge
where people commit suicide all the time
yeah it saved my happy place
this is disrespectful you're prancing
around like some amusement park
that captions just why clearly i've
never been to a burial
it's not a happy place for anyone dude
people just need to get off their
[ __ ] phones i bury my father
like sir material i love cemeteries
they're beautiful especially that one
it's historical and i love history go to
play
i'd be like shut your ass up right i
wouldn't even i wouldn't even give that
to you
i don't know why she remember i'd be
like yeah eat a dick that that reminds
me of like what do i owe you
it reminds me of like the nightmare
before christmas great movie by the way
mm-hmm what does that mean those
pictures the nightmare before
it's a great movie that picture right
there reminds me it's scary that's
beautiful it's a great
great and by the way that's a habit what
are you mad at yeah what are you mad
about
look at that sometimes i'll go to the
hollywood forever cemetery
it's just nice well is it disrespectful
that the hollywood cemetery has a movie
yeah exactly they have movie nights
there yeah that could be someone's happy
place again dude can you imagine writing
that comment on her brother i know
going all the way down this is just
disrespectful to write that
people people have been kind of like
looking out for her to [ __ ] up ever
since she
had that statement about corona do you
remember early on
we did a story on it where she basically
won instagram live and people asked her
to say something about the coronavirus
and she's virus sorry i tried
she said something along the lines of
like the coronavirus is terrible but
like
people are going to die anyways and
she's right yeah she's right she
basically got canceled for like
from that and she had to apologize i
hate how society like make like for one
like let's just be honest bro we bring
go ahead go ahead okay
all right what are we going to say no
it's just this shit's annoying
it's just like why do you what i don't
know go ahead you frustrated you
but you're good cancel her over her
perspective on corona you know why does
it matter to you why does her
perspective on corona mean that much to
you to where you're like oh i need a
canceler
this is the weirdest [ __ ] people it's
just unhappy people so yeah
you have to be you have to literally
like it shouldn't matter to you it's
what you
[ __ ] feel what happened what is
what's up with people's own
[ __ ] feelings what happened to that
why why don't people worry about their
own [ __ ] people are sheep they have
nothing they do
why do you have to worry about what the
[ __ ] vanessa you don't know her
she doesn't even know you called [ __ ]
chappelle no sorry i'm getting a little
crazy
you know what were you saying you look
into it it's frustrating look into it
the only thing more frustrating is one
of malik's
news reports so wait
sorry timeout you'd rather read a
comment about you or my news reports
let's be honest
neither but you just have me read both
of them right yeah
it was literally like a little
elementary school kid reading an
announcement
right now you get to read the
announcement yeah
cheryl having a bakery you brought these
up last week we didn't get to him though
scott mcdonald's baby oh it's nuts right
how big
uh a jump mcdonald's has had in sales
since travis scott jumped on board
that's the wildest thing they can't miss
yeah i mean they need to take for other
companies to take note man
come on
i literally had it back to back you two
back to back dude
yeah come on back-to-back
that spicy deluxe clothes on sunday
you don't need a celebrity endorsement
oh yeah 100
they're just killing it killing it yeah
i never understood why you know what's
so funny people go
just people go people want chick-fil-a
on sunday and they go [ __ ] it's sunday i
can't get chick-fil-a
[ __ ] to get it the next day
maybe i'm just speaking for myself but
it's true
i agree with you yeah you want what you
can't have yeah you're like oh i'll just
get it tomorrow
and you're like oh it's open today [ __ ]
it yeah
but yeah top of the week man much like
monday but but they're doing another
uh collab with uh what's his name jay
baldwin yeah
who's that who's that uh latin you would
know
he has some slappers he does no i know
romeo santos
he has his own j's too me too oh he does
yeah
they didn't hook up romeo santos um
with cardi b i like it that was huge oh
that was him
i like it like that he came on and
started doing that sauce to it
okay i like him okay oh that's okay i
like it
i respect him don't make that jay balvin
man get your deal
i don't know you but yeah you know he
has his own jordans his own jordan john
jordan once
wait hold on i need to see you're coming
out what are you going to do you know
that ripmo was you know the ripmo song
from bad boys
away from bad boys click on that chin
you i guarantee you've heard this song
yeah
with will i am it's the rhythm of the
night oh yeah
oh it's slower than i thought it was i
was off speed for a second shout out to
the black eyed peas i've been heard from
them in a minute
oh bro that guy peas have been staying
with it
you think they give up you know him
right yeah i know this song
yep he's got his own jordans too yeah
they're dope we're going to get your own
jordans
more work to do i want my own vans
that's what i want speaking into
existence oh bieber is getting his own
crocs
that's just a bird [ __ ] on my damn vans
i tried to wipe it out but it's still
there i can tell i know
yeah those are the jordan ones oh that
was awesome you're gonna get those
brendan uh i dig them they too colorful
though brenda you're going to get them
yeah i'll probably get them yeah
how much are they does it say they
didn't release them they're waiting
they're pretty spicy though how much you
you guys spend so much on shoes
yeah everyday new shoes yeah that's so
crazy
you said every day you wear different
shoes every day well yeah i try not to
go back to back
really yeah 130 i'm not drake typically
i'm at face value yeah
sell out faster you have to aftermarket
so
so when that stuff sells out you go to
aftermarket how much are you looking at
on aftermarket
i have a plug so i'm looking at probably
300. shout out to the plug
we
[Laughter]
his name okay he does people figure it
out oh yeah they'll figure out
bro they've been leaving they've been
leaving comments on his photos oh so
you're the one
you don't want to like
yeah you see me you see me coming up
right i'm like
what are you coming up this is so funny
followers yeah yeah
you see my coming up right now go to
this page [ __ ] it [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] it
show
[Laughter]
look at my guy bro y'all need to go
follow justin the funniest guy
look at him look at this looking at him
i think watch hold on wait yeah that's
fine
go to his comments on that one the first
photo
i think someone said you're the one
can i join the can i join the frat love
you king keep watching
the bottom one oh so this is the justin
y'all talking about like the big girls
[Laughter]
i like how they use that long oh yeah
by the water look at this picture
he's from miami he's chilling just
chilling still no baby
big girls haul at him hell yeah you say
you've been thriving black king thriving
thrive man thrives my guy hilarious he's
been thriving
so [ __ ] hopefully catch some big old
salty one in uh phoenix when we're there
oh he got he got a couple oh so last
time it wasn't oh i won't say it but
yeah yeah
yeah if you won't say that don't put
that don't say that
sometimes you gotta change for the
better yeah
look at this he looks like
right i love you changing i was there
when uh
adrian took that picture he was like i
liked it
hey look
yeah right i'm sitting there like oh he
was like yo this is exactly what he said
he was like not adrian i'ma look over my
shoulder really
and i'm gonna need you to get that oh
that was outside hollywood yeah exactly
right there
yeah i was like you i was like bro she
did she said uh ovo jacket yeah ovo yeah
how about he was a paralegal he's a
paralegal
yeah he's a smart dude yeah these are
very smart you got chin
another one of yours sirius xm and
howard stern
did they finally agree to the deal i
know they offer him 125 a year
i think he said that he is renewing yeah
125. wait what happened
i i mean obviously they're they're doing
it right i don't get wait see this is
why i can't work for penis i'm not stern
but i'm
not nobody either oh yeah because uh
some beef well they're not paying
attention marshall
is also with sirius and i don't think
they're paying up
siriusxm has 34 million paying
subscribers
7.8 billion sales last year god i just i
don't know
anybody who [ __ ] with serious i just i
don't know anybody
i love howard stern too i i mean you
haven't here's the thing out of those 38
million subscribers
how many of those come in rental cars
it's only people i know
oh yeah i was just about to say that
you're right yeah so what
uh dave is wanting that howard stern
money too
i don't think he expects that but um
i'm sure he wants is he is he big enough
to to get that kind of
barstool is i don't think dave himself
hosting a show is big enough to
oh he's hosting that bar but the
collection is [ __ ]
big killing it got it i love bar stool
oh you do yeah that's what you get
so you guys are those are my guys yeah
well i've been on bars
but i've been like at the headquarters
at barstool with dave and kfc and the
boys for
i don't know now five six years like
those are really guys yeah
they crush it they're just dudes who had
a dream and they they own everything
they did have a deal with espn but
because they're so outlandish their deal
got cancelled
but they own all their [ __ ] all their
masters yeah
you're talking you're talking about bros
with an idea who capitalized it
capitalized on it and they're i think
they're coming out evaluated at like 300
million like
dude they're big really big big ballers
big ballers
uh big cat all those boys are my guys
that's tight yeah
yeah and then blew the fire so what is
it so what does it entail
they have a they have podcast branch
merch website
you know and then they have a show on
sirius oh right on then they have
they have their own betting lines they
have their own fight league yeah they
have their own
uh uh fancy football league they have
they have a sports podcast they have uh
caller daddy podcast
they have kfc they have big cat they
have pardon my take like they're
the boys yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah
busting with the boys my boy will
compton
yeah they shout out to these guys yeah
they have so they have a football
podcast they have deion sanders as the
host
oh that's great yeah pro football they
know what the [ __ ] they're doing
their their demo 18 to 36 mail they
dominate
and it's what espn fox everybody wants
they have it
they have it and then they're located
now portnoy that the
the president they become uh the
president of presidential presidente
he's worth like a hundred million bucks
really he flies private has a place in
[ __ ] hamptons like baller
we're the hamptons uh outside new york
oh
god damn shout out to the housewives but
again they're just bros
they're just these girls just that was
just a damn thing yeah
i respect it and they're funny dude
they're funny oh yeah
[ __ ] yeah you listen to kfc your big cat
and the rest of the crew like they're
funny dudes but
how long you been doing them like six
years i probably been going there doing
their shows for like five or six years
man
they've always supported me i've always
supported them that's love of course
yeah
real recognized real damn
uh someone a fan his name is barney's
not purple on instagram wanted me to
send you this shout out to morning shout
out to barney
kevin costner actually posts a phone
number we could actually contact him
and talk about yellowstone if you want
wait what happened you know i'm headed
to montana
so there's this number if you want to
talk about that that's the view from
hell or high water
yeah the one that gets killed and uh
jeff bridges
goes off oh oh he's doing because he has
a new album
and he he's down to talk about
yellowstone too i don't know the
bodyguard
the guy who played in the bodyguard has
an album
coming out have you heard of the music
channel this i just wrote it through
this
which you can't really tell much is it
better than go to go to youtube
you need to tell me yes it's better
mr brooks got an album coming out he
worked with whitney houston i wouldn't
doubt it
alright the queen the sun will rise
again yeah let's hear this [ __ ]
okay oh [ __ ] i look at him in a
different light i love him
dude yellowstone makes me want to move
out of california one just um
thinking out loud he looks just like my
dad
oh really you got to go from there why
are you doing like that
what are you doing
[Applause]
[Music]
i respect it now this is hard this
nashville
that dude look like dean delray on the
base i was just gonna
that dude and dean del rey can play he
can play oh wait oh him right here no
no no no no it looks like dean oh
that looks like deandre del rey or josh
potter i might go to the concert
he didn't say i should do my own punk
album you know all these
what would you call it let me see
something else laced up
laced ooh laced up here oh no lace up
was a machine gun kelly
i was like yeah this is what it is it's
mgk no that's his thing he says
lace up that's also the name of his
album oh i thought it was like his brand
name was that this has 1.2 million 1.9
and 1.2 million views uh where did that
come out
already nine years ago oh nine years ago
okay
oh so he's been playing for a hot second
i guess so
hey look at chin on the violin
[Laughter]
i didn't see it well i don't want to see
cheers
why not it's not for me but yeah i
support them
do you like this better than vin diesel
or do you like i like that vendetta
he was hey ben if you're listening do it
live
please do it live we'll do it live [ __ ]
it imagine
imagine him imagine him yet his voice
speaking of vin diesel that's the
current event too
oh you know he does random posts that i
just don't get yeah so this is another
one of us why is he so close
talk that talk man he always does this
hold on let me refresh too near me not
to hear me come on talk that talk [ __ ]
you near me not to hear me
[Music]
you see that rainbow behind me no no i
don't see oh yeah i see it right there
underneath the cloud
yeah sign of brighter days to come what
i want to thank all of you for being so
supportive brighter days you're in a 40
million dollar mansion
right out of my comfort zone i make
music
uh during these times i'm so grateful
scoot the camera back all right
he's so out of touch dominated me is the
nel star
of 2020. for the people's choice award
and the action mail star
2020 and bloodshot uh which is how the
feels like he's saying this with his
eyes closed
you're the best fans in the world and uh
i'm just you ain't gonna cry so grateful
for everyone you ain't gonna cry
all the voters watch in the beginning he
moves his mouth
so he's singing along to his song in the
background
he sounded like me explaining the news
article i know right it's just a bit of
a tool
she's a bit of a tool i mean she came in
there's a bomb there's another 13
minutes
hey
things are rough right now 40 million
dollar mansion yeah
you got rainbow that means things are
gonna get better for us everybody he's
just too famous and rich
he's just he's just he doesn't have a
good crew around and be like hey don't
post that
yeah i think it's a big thing if you're
going to post you know how you're seeing
in the beginning dude that looks
terrible
he post videos like how your grandma be
facetiming no like granny move back from
the phone grin
oh go the one with the mascot i can't
get enough of them though
i don't have to watch these videos so
i'm on my way to do adr
why is he so close i don't know trying
to tell you it's like a grandparent dude
let's be like this
someone's a microphone cable come on
these oh here's
uh can you plug it in that uh thing
that's sticking out right there
thank you so excited for you hear me now
yeah yeah
um i won't even tease it i'll just say
that i'm so excited for you to hear it
what are you talking about dude this is
a song people that have encouraged me to
bro look at that first comment for
singing
ah hold up pause it chin she's the
reflection is glasses
yeah there's a screen
do you see how yeah what's he doing
there's like two screens it might be his
phone
or something uh i don't know it could
just be his car
the comment says it's beautiful without
a mask with the mask you look even more
beautiful
that's like messed up and in that kind
of like a derogatory thing like dude you
look better with the mask on yeah even
more beautiful
yeah it's just thirsty comment just a
thirsty comment
you think he replied yeah i wouldn't no
no he didn't oh okay
privately copy that
yeah he always does these well go go the
red one
i think we watched this one already
after chronicles of riddick just came in
nobody thought he was you remember
brandon told us he was gay
i lied it's nothing short of incredible
david tui you did it again
what what you did the best writing would
come out of this covered pandemic
and you proved that might get his lips
done huh excited yeah he has like red
spots in his eyes too
uh just a quick reminder um if it
doesn't have the blue tick on it
his teeth too be weary he's got stitches
in his left his right eyebrows yeah
to anybody uh so be
be cautious about all the scammers that
have been
uh created out of the decimal what is
happening dude
he looks tired um you can fall asleep to
his voice though
oh it's nice you never can fall asleep
tonight oh you're like
hell yeah i'm gonna put this ben diesel
on
a meditation meditation yeah yeah oh
yeah man tell me something
it's beautiful i'll kick it with him
hell yeah of course
yeah baby it's so sweet i don't know
you're confused it's like i don't know i
don't know i'm on board
with him it's like when my boys were
going over sevester lone's house and
there's like all these stars humble
breath it's just like an ego
like pissing oh oh i got you gotcha like
still talking about old movies they did
i'm like
what yeah yeah but the [ __ ] are we doing
that voice
yeah you got a point i got a like what
are you talking about i don't know what
the [ __ ] you do
oh it's a current event a little mouse
this is a real underscore talk
underscore fishing i just saw this i
thought it was really really cool
tell me wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait every time
i watch i think you're gonna think it's
cool too because i never would have
imagined this
okay so let me just guess yeah the rat
the toe gonna eat the rat
and he the red is already in he the toe
will get eaten by a snake
no man you got one part right but did
you know toads eat
rats it's giant never thought about it i
mean
i assume you know if they're hungry
enough because he's a giant
his toad's like oh hell no so there's no
snake
it's a cute little rat too that fast
snake would have killed without that
that mouse has to still be alive in his
stomach yeah
you think you'd fight out no i think
something would like
acid in there but not right away but it
will not right away but
basically yeah and you know toads are
frogs they're like
cannibals they don't need each other
each other yeah yeah yeah i know that
though
vile animals great video chin
thanks man that was cool real talk
fishing i mean i can't
honestly i can't i respect vin diesel
you can't get on a vin digital bandwagon
no i can't get enough of it
100 it's a complete mess wait what it's
a mess
it is a mess but it's fun to watch it's
fun to watch yeah
i say keep posting well hopefully
hopefully he comes on the show
so i don't know how real this is but
your boy justin wren posted this oh this
is real yeah really is it real
that's just crazy so this is a
coronavirus type school dance this is
what they're doing
okay what
[Music]
because you know your faces aren't like
in front of each other less chance to
catch the virus why have a problem
i don't know but it looks crazy how come
ain't no black people at this
that's a good question so far a great
question hey there's no asian either i
don't think black people would have a
back to back dance though chappelle
our asses are too big yeah this dad's
like what the
[ __ ] yeah what a nightmare
dude yeah that's just crazy the hennessy
would not let black people do that
no wow that was that was weird but
wait where is that by the way i'm not
kidding yes no i'm curious now
it has a let's just i want it so
disappointing
at least they get to go to a dance
though no what they don't have
at home that's not even a dance i'm sure
they have i'm sure they had a choice to
stay home they all went
yeah but david was gonna dance like that
yeah like girl kiss my ass i was like
what you mean back to back what no hell
no it was so so weird
i mean how does one parent not go how
many children
under 16 have died why are we doing this
and then you have to have a
have to wear a mask while you have my
back towards me but you guys are still
touching like that that doesn't make any
sense it's so stupid but you're facing
someone else
yeah the other they're facing each other
yeah it's just stupid [ __ ]
that's dumb i hate people yeah what else
you got chin last one
right here 1500 birds
flew into some of the philly's tallest
skyscrapers in one day
last week but this is like two weeks
away why so they think it's because of
first of all uh the weather change
something with the weather and also a
migration period but the fact that they
had one
like one single day 1500 that just
crashed into the walls and died
yeah but also if birds are stupid enough
to hit those windows
dude i would see it all i thought i'd be
a crazier i thought it'd be like some
other crazier type of event like you
know
but i guess it's just yeah migration
patterns
and weather but that would be some sort
of like crazy phenomenon
so i would see it all the time i worked
at a hotel it was like all glass
in arizona yeah and they were literally
all the time started on nemo damn hit it
and survive
uh one did it lay there for a while and
we were like oh [ __ ] how do we move it
and all of a sudden it just got up and
then peaced out
guys i've never seen anything like it
there were birds everywhere they were
all dead
it was that malik that was it they were
they were dead
girls i immediately jumped out of bed
this was a big deal
i just can't stop thinking about it
i'll tell you right now i will not think
about these stupid birds
it won't the last thing i'll [ __ ]
think about
birds are [ __ ] stupid what was that
[ __ ] movie or the happening
yeah a lot of people hated it i loved it
it's kind of it's like
goofy that was the m night shyamalacka
movie
it was supposed to be you know it has
happened before
is that it that's it all right chappelle
you're me and tampa
yeah i'll see you i'll see you there
friday saturday tampa
two shows friday two show saturdays two
shows seven shows
two one show thursday two shows friday
three shows
oh you working one show sunday so
oh wow when you come back i get back
monday morning
at like 10 30. oh you working
i'm working you're working yeah i know
um
straight off the flight to here tight
move doug yeah let him know jet life
doug
yep see come on do a video like vin
diesel
uh you should but all we should see is
the gap you want me to do it
uh this cruise in phoenix november 5th
through the 7th those tickets are almost
sold out
stand up live in phoenix then nashville
zany's come get it nashville november
19th
21st tickets right now tfatkay.com get
em
thickboygear thickboy.com that's it
thanks for doing it firing the kids
the kids the kids